annalena baerbock bei uns vor werbung
grünen-chefin und grosse wahlsiegerin
fühlen sich gut getroffen gefällt ihnen
das
ja geht so köpfe auf körper kommt glaube
ich nicht so gut aber okay okay danke
dass ich schön gebastelt haben vermag
haben sie damit gerechnet dass sie da so
heute als sieger als siegerin aus der
wahl aus den beiden wahlen rausgehen
ich freue mich natürlich erstmal sehr
dass wir in baden württemberg jetzt zum
dritten mal stärkste kraft sind und vor
allen dingen dass die grünen baden
württemberg winfried kretschmann das
ergebnis noch mal erhöhen konnte weil es
auch zeigt dass in schwierigen
situationen in einer nicht einfachen
zeit wo ja auch das vertrauen der
politik angeknackst ist wie als grüne
immer mehr vertrauen gewinnen und
deswegen ist es natürlich ein guter
start in dieses super wahlkampfjahr für
uns grüne mit wem von denen die hier vor
uns stehen würden sie denn am liebsten
koalieren also nehmen wir an sie treten
an als kanzlerkandidatin der grünen das
hört man ja immer mehr dass das
vielleicht schon eigentlich entschieden
sein könnte und gegen wen von denen
würden sie am liebsten nicht antreten
das entscheiden robert habeck und ich
zwischen ostern und pfingsten aber auch
am wahlabend wo ich mich sehr freue
ist für mich total klar es geht jetzt
nicht darum was ist meine liebste wahl
kombination was ist meine liebste macht
kombination sondern was ist das beste
für unser land wir sind mitten in einer
pandemie ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen
geht aber nicht reiben wirklich die
sorgen um was gerade an unseren schulen
passiert warum das mit dem impfstoff
nicht schneller vorangeht und vor allen
dingen macht ja dieses jahr aber macht
vor allen dingen auch diese wahl noch
mal so deutlich wie wichtig es ist dass
wir in zukunft auch eine andere art von
politik machen mehr mit menschen im
gespräch seien verwaltung viel viel
schneller wirklich auch eine effektiven
starte alle mit dem blick hat und das
ist finde ich die große aufgabe unserer
zeit und dann ab september auch für die
nächste bundesregierung bei der wahl
heute abend in beiden bundesländern
spricht man ja davon dass auch eine
krone abrechnung ist es geht bei weitem
nicht nur um die einzelnen bundesländer
sondern um das was die wähler jetzt das
ganze jahr gesehen haben die grünen
können heute sehr zufrieden auf die
ergebnisse blicken
glauben sie das liegt auch daran wie sie
sich in dieser corona krise jetzt
positioniert haben oder sind das
tatsächlich erfolge ihrer land
beides und winfried kretschmann der
jetzt so viel vertrauen auch bei dieser
wahl bekommen hat war er einer der
ministerpräsidenten der immer sehr sehr
deutlich gemacht hat wir müssen sehr
vorsichtig sein aber wir müssen vor
allen dingen auch gerecht sein darauf
schauen wer braucht eigentlich am
meisten unterstützung und er hat ja
immer wieder deutlich gemacht ihm liegen
familien ihm liegen kinder sehr am
herzen da ist es ja auch mal zum disput
mit der bundeskanzlerin gekommen die er
immer gesagt hatten er aber das mit den
schulen das nehmen wir jetzt mal lieber
nicht auf die tagesordnung und da sieht
man glaube ich dass so eine politik die
sagt wir brauchen vor allen dingen
vorsorge wir müssen vorausschauend
agieren damit wir bestmöglich
vorbereitet sind dass die anerkennung
bekommt ich meine wir grünen haben auch
nicht alles richtig gemacht ja also das
ist ja nicht so dass irgendjemand hier
perfekt im letzten jahr unterwegs war
aber für mich macht das schon deutlich
wie wichtig es ist die menschen in den
mittelpunkt von politischen
entscheidungen zu stellen und nicht zu
sagen ja als erstes machen wir da wieder
auf die am lautesten schreien und man
hat ja schon so das gefühl dass sie vor
allem mit diesem erfolgsrezept nicht zu
viel zu kritisieren gewonnen haben
werden die spd in der regierung hart zum
beispiel das impfstoff desaster
angeklagt hat auch beim testen hatte man
manchmal das gefühl naja sie schielen
alle ich darauf dass ich schon bald mit
der union regieren und deswegen halte
sich besonders zurück warum sind sie
über diesen themen die ja auch viele
bürger sehr sehr beschäftigen dass es
mit dem impfen so langsam geht beim
testen und bei den perspektiven sind so
zurückhaltend da sind ja aus meiner
sicht nicht wir haben anfang dieser
pandemie also ich weiß ich da noch
niemand in einer pandemie sie ja auch
nicht haben wir sehr deutlich gemacht
wie behaupten jetzt nicht von uns wir
wissen alles wie das virus weiter agiert
und deswegen haben wir zu beginn nämlich
letztes jahr in ostern gesagt wir
unterstützen den damaligen kurs der
bundesregierung wirklich erst mal in
einen lock down reinzugehen wirklich
erst mal gemeinsam zu überlegen wie
kommen wir bestmöglich daraus aber als
wir gesehen haben dass eben die
bundesregierung immer nur auf sicht
gefahren ist ja alles fing an mit dem
schutz materialien es war vollkommen
klar wir brauchen vor allen dingen viele
viele masken habe ich vorgeschlagen
damals schon im frühling letzten jahres
wir brauchen so etwas wie eine pandemie
wirtschaft wo wir wirklich unternehmen
sagen ihr müsst eure produktion
hochfahren hatten wir die sommerferien
wo nichts passierte
den schulen hatte ich auch immer wieder
deutlich gemacht leute lasst uns die
ferien nutzen lüftungs filteranlagen in
den schulen einbauen wir haben sehr
konstruktiv gesagt wir unterstützen euch
dabei und haben dann leider gesehen dass
leider dieser kurs immer nur auf sicht
fahren immer hinterher zu hinken sich
fort geführt hat und ja deswegen haben
wir jetzt in jüngster zeit nochmal
deutlich auch unsere kritik verschärft
weil wir gesehen haben
es passiert einfach nicht nicht zum
beispiel bei den schnelltest ja aus
meiner sicht kinder müssten im
mittelpunkt der politik stehen das heißt
alle schnell das zur selbstanwendung
jetzt vor allen dingen an die schulen
damit wir da nicht mal ein mal die woche
testen können was ja noch gar nicht
richtig angelaufen ist weil dann sparen
leider die schnell test nicht dorthin
bringen sondern regelmäßig testen können
weil die situation für viele kinder ist
wirklich hoch dramatisch wenn sie drauf
schauen auf die frage wie es jetzt in
deutschland weitergehen sollen wir sehen
die zahlen steigen wieder an und sie
haben gesagt die grünen haben sich immer
positioniert so ein bisschen als die
vorsichtigen werden sie dann dafür wenn
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
stattfindet dass der maßnahmen wieder
verschärft werden glauben sie dass wir
wieder in einen neuen look down in diese
dritte welle gehen werden oder wie
glauben sie werden die nächsten wochen
und monate aus ihrer sicht sein als was
ich einfordere ist dass worte und taten
wirklich miteinander übereinstimmen es
bringt nichts wenn ministerpräsidenten
dann sagen wir sind total vorsichtig und
da machen wir aber mal da die baumärkte
wieder auf und dann nehmen wir die
inzidenz einmal nicht so ernst sondern
man muss in so schwierigen situationen
wirklich prioritäten setzen in der krise
gilt es darum dass jemand
führungsverantwortung übernimmt und sagt
dieses ding das ist jetzt das weg und
das macht die konsole nicht das macht
die bundesregierung viel zu wenig volle
priorität auf die frage jetzt die
impfstoffe wirklich überall hin zu
bekommen deutlich auch zu machen
wie kann es sein dass jetzt mit
astrazeneca europa wieder weniger
impfstoff bekommt und vor allen dingen
wie gesagt diese schnelltests zur
selbstanwendung ich weiß nicht warum wir
jetzt sparen und auch die kanzlerin so
hadern flächendeckend vor allen dingen
an schulen an kitas und überall zur
selbstanwendung hin raum und daneben
deutlich zu machen dass wir so sicher
durch die nächsten wochen kommen anstatt
das jetzt unterschiedlichste bereiche
geöffnet werden ohne wirkliches
gesundheitskonzept die tests und auch
die impfungen sind zwei themen die oft
auch dadurch aufgefallen sind das
versprechen abgegeben worden
indem ich eingehalten werden konnten das
vertrauen der wähler ist dadurch
natürlich oft erschüttert worden jetzt
der masten skandal natürlich vor allem
die union trifft aber inwiefern glauben
sie sind die menschen in deutschland
jetzt verunsichert
inwiefern sie überhaupt politikern egal
von welcher partei noch vertrauen können
und was wollen sie machen um zu zeigen
uns kann man vertrauen
vor allen dingen ehrliche politik machen
und nicht dinge versprechen die man da
nicht wirklich pragmatisch umsetzt
sondern endlich auch pragmatisch an
dinge heranzugehen jemand zu sagen wir
diskutieren das jetzt noch mal fünf
wochen aus aber in der partei passiert
überhaupt nichts führungsverantwortung
zu übernehmen
ich bin dafür verantwortlich dass es
jetzt in diesen bereichen läuft und ich
glaube ja da muss es mit blick auf die
nächste bundestagswahl wirklich auch ein
neues zeitalter in politik in dem
verständnis von politik aufgeschlagen
werden weil das jetzt bei der union die
frage wie kommen wir durch die korona
situation und der masken skandal so
ineinander zusammenkommen kann man denn
überhaupt noch koalieren wenn dieser
mast können da sich ausweitet das ist
halt kein zufall weil es ist eine frage
von einem macht verständnis definiere
ich eigentlich meine verantwortung für
dieses land darüber zu sagen na ja ich
mache das schon irgendwie mit meinen
seilschaften und irgendwie wird es schon
funktionieren und das sieht man in
diesen masken skandale wie sich das für
sie eine rolle bei der koalition suchen
dann nach der wahl wenn sie die chance
haben zu regieren würden sie dann eher
sagen na ja also bei der union da haben
wir das was sie jetzt gerade beschrieben
haben erlebt mit denen wollen wir
eigentlich nicht
also erstmal müssen wir ja in einen
wahlkampf komme ich finde es jetzt
wirklich einige haben sich heute schon
zum kanzler für die nächste
regierungszeit ausgerufen und dabei
wurde gerade in bundesländern gewählt
das schöne in einer demokratie ist ja
dass wählerinnen und wähler deutlich
machen welcher partei vertraue ich
eigentlich am meisten und ich werbe
darum dass wir gemeinsam als
gesellschaft sowie diese gesellschaft in
der krise über sich hinaus gewachsen ist
muss politik jetzt endlich über sich
hinauswachsen und sagen in gewissen
bereichen läuft es in zukunft anders das
ist mit blick auf die soziale
absicherung krankenhäuser pflegekräfte
müssen endlich besser unterstützt werden
das ist mit blick auf familien und
kinder die gehören in den mittelpunkt
von politik und wir müssen
vorausschauend agieren die nächste krise
steht vor der tür das ist die
klimakrise und wenn wir da jetzt
wirklich so handeln dass wir
verantwortungsvolle politik machen dann
können wir unseren industriestandort
klimaneutral machen und das bußgeld
rechnen denn industriestandort an
winfried kretschmann hat ja mit einer
industriefreundlichen politik mit einer
pragmatischen politik in baden
württemberg diese wahl gewonnen
und wenn man jetzt diese politik mit
ihrer oder der in berlin vergleicht dann
haben wir eigentlich nicht so viel
gemein da müssen sie sich wenn sie
kanzlerin werden wollen am ende mehr an
baden württemberg orientieren
das hat sehr viel miteinander zu tun
dass winfried kretschmann in baden
württemberg gemacht hat mit uns grünen
er sich ja schließlich ein grüner
ministerpräsident
und wir haben vor über einem jahr
gemeinsam den co2 preis dafür gesorgt
dass er nicht wie von cdu und csu und
spd vorgeschlagen bei zehn euro ist
sondern bei 25 euro weil dieser preis
zum beispiel dafür sorgt dass diejenigen
mittelständer handwerksbetriebe große
industrieunternehmen dass die wenn sie
jetzt auf klimaneutralität umstellen
nicht in die röhre gucken weil die
anderen die einfach mit den fossilen
weitermachen eigentlich bessere chancen
am markt haben sondern dass die wirklich
in zukunft und innovation gehen
unterstützt werden haben wir stark an
einem strang gezogen und das wollen wir
demnächst ja auch auf bundesebene
und ich glaube es ist schon signal dass
gerade in der herzkammer der deutschen
industrie des deutschen mittelstands
jetzt ein grüner ministerpräsident zum
dritten mal wiedergewählt worden ist
inwiefern werden solche themen aber in
diesem jahr beim wahlkampf eine rolle
spielen die korona krise überschattet
seit einem jahr alles und das wird auch
bis september befürchten wir nicht
anders seine krise beschleunigt beendet
sein ist aber platz für viele andere
themen dann noch im wahlkampf ja weil
aus meiner sicht ist ja nicht so die
leute sagen oh das virus das ist das was
mich total umtreibt sondern die menschen
treibt doch um das wir nach wie vor in
einem industrieland achse zwischen
gesundheitsämtern hin und herschicken
dass wir bei dem bildungs ranking hinter
ländern sind wo immer glauben ja ja die
sind bei der wirtschaftliche entwicklung
ja noch nicht so weit voran dass die
digitalisierung in bildung gar nicht
stattgefunden hat die leute traf doch um
das sie sagen meine güte werden jetzt in
dieser schwierigen zeit unternehmen
unterstützt werden warum geben wird
milliarden an die lufthansa ohne zu
sagen wie soll eigentlich so ein konzern
in zukunft aufgebaut werden das heißt
alle themen wo viele menschen das kann
ich total verstehen jetzt in dieser
corona situation echt auch enttäuscht
von politik sind sind zentrale
politische felder sozialpolitik
umweltpolitik arbeitsmarktpolitik und
deswegen werden die aus meiner sicht
auch bei der nächsten bundestagswahl
eine große rolle spielen und wir haben
jetzt ja auch bei denen wahlnachfragen
gesehen dass die menschen eben viel
stärker darauf schauen was machen
politikerinnen und politiker dann
wirklich wenn sie gewählt worden sind
und das ist auch mein anspruch von
politik nicht nur zu versprechen sondern
dann pragmatisch auch zu handeln was ist
das erste was sie tun würden sie
schaffen kannst du dann zu werben und
deutschland als sie doch mal ich weiß
dass ich hier gerne die kanzlerin frage
heraus kitzelt wollen aber alles zu
seiner zeit
robert habeck und ich klären zwischen
ostern und pfingsten wer für uns
antreibt was glauben sie wann klären die
beiden das und auf wen setzen sie da was
glauben sie gegen wen werden sie
antreten naja vielleicht ist ihre
gesichtsmimik da ein kleines indiz sowie
sind die aus das müssen sie die beiden
herren fragen wie sie das miteinander
regeln wollen und die union glauben sie
die die werden jetzt in der tiefe krise
noch weiter stürzen in den nächsten
wochen glauben sie das geht noch weiter
beim us-team skandal bei der frage was
da im hintergrund gelaufen ist was für
geschäfte mit aserbaidschan die dinge
die da hoch gekommen sind ich meinen sie
sind sie kennen die ihre kollegen der
bundestag glauben sie da liegt noch mehr
ich würde sagen ich hoffe nicht aber
meine große sorge ist weil jetzt wurde
ja gesagt jetzt unterschreibt man brief
dass ihr beim nächsten skandal nicht
irgendwas gruppen gedrehtes getrieben
habe aber es geht ja nicht nur um die
masten skandal und das muss doch die
erkenntnis sein ja hier geht es um
vertrauen in politiker wenn wir gewählt
werden als bundestagsabgeordnete ob ich
wirklich das beste für mein land geben
das beste für die gesellschaft gebe ob
ich oder ob ich die hälfte meiner zeit
zeit eigentlich damit verbringen
nebenbei das beste für mich hier raus
hat schon mal jemand was angeboten so
also kommt es bei den grünen auf vor das
dann mal weil sie nicht jedem land
ankommt und sagt ich sponsoren jetzt
eine gartenparty
nein das ist aber dass da das zeigt dass
es ein unterschiedliches kulturelles
verständnis gibt weil wir sind natürlich
als abgeordnete mit sehr
der vielen ländern in kontakt ich war
selber früher mal in der europarats
delegation und das ist das was mich
wirklich so umtreibt und dass das macht
mich ja so sauer weil ich meine wir
leben in einer demokratie wir können so
dankbar sein dass wir parlamente haben
und dann wird durch einige das vertrauen
so stark zerstört und gerade das mit
blick auf aserbaidschan ich meine das
ist eine diktatur das muss halt mal so
deutlich sagen linien bombardiert die
armenien bombardiert haben die sich
gerade als demokratie versucht haben
wirklich stark auf die füße zu stellen
und gerade die frage mit aserbaidschan
die war bekannt die war in der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion bekannt die
abgeordneten die da betroffen sind hat
ein hausverbot im europarat das ist das
gremium sozusagen das
menschenrechtsgremium aller
europäerinnen und europäer und deswegen
gilt es jetzt wirklich mit blick auf die
cdu nicht nur zu sagen kriegen wir diese
masken affäre vom tisch sondern um
vertrauen in politik zurückzugewinnen
wirklich bereit zu sein sagen wir ändern
strukturell was das macht immer nur
geborgte verantwortung auf zeit ist und
deswegen haben wir vorgeschlagen als
grüne zum beispiel im bundestag jetzt
dafür zu sorgen dass alles auf cent und
euro offengelegt werden muss und dass
eben auch so nebentätigkeiten wie
aktienoptionen dass die alle
veröffentlicht werden müssen
herzlichen dank für ihren besuch bei
bild live
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren